okay I've done my focus helmet and
loaded it up with two tall boys of
concentration Jews and I have my browser
open to the wiki a DC Comics base in
case I miss a reference I have a white
board to help me keep track of the
interrelationships between the alternate
realities I am finally ready to read
Grant Morrison's Multiversity this is a
comic that's been five years in the
making and true I have spent most of
that time griping about how these lazy
jerks need to finish the damn thing but
all is forgiven
it's finally here visionary slash
lunatic slash Scotsman Grant Morrison
has conceived of a mind-bending eight
issue miniseries that sprawls across 52
parallel universes which feature
everything from a Nazi Superman into a
vampire Batman to the spoiled lazy
children of superheroes who live like
characters in MTV's the hills
Multiversity is so complex that it comes
with an intricate map
always a good sign as far as I'm
concerned and it doesn't just re-examine
the standard pantheon in the DC Universe
it pulls in characters from Old World
War 2 era DC Comics or Fawcett comics
old Charlton comics Jack Kirby's
commanding captain carrot suddenly it
feels like devoting my life to keeping
track of all this junk was actually a
worthwhile endeavor I was born to read
this and Grant Morrison was born to
write he was shaped from childhood to be
a comic writer the timing was sec city
well it's all clearly spelled out in
flex meant a low number 2 I don't have
to rehash it now some writers approached
costume do-gooders with disdain it's all
just childish quasi fascist escapism to
them but Morrison fervently believes
that we need superheroes that there's a
good reason that humankind dreamed up
this archetype he's also the best
present for the job because he really
really really believes in superheroes
he's convinced that his scribblings can
bring things into existence when his
comics get self-reflexive when he has
his characters speak directly to readers
he isn't winking at you or breaking the
fourth wall he's convinced that this
primary colored puppy stuff is actually
happening on some level don't believe me
just listen magic works and when I
started in the comic a thing that you
could actually make magic happen by
writing things and changing the
operating system of the universe
changing the operating system what does
that even mean Morrison I did it cane of
your blue turn your bums out there one
day look I don't care how far out there
he is as long as he channels all of that
craziness into his work but one thing
concerns me if Multiversity appeals this
much to an obsessive like me it's
probably not going to be a mass market
phenomena in any way shape or form will
it sell so poorly the DC abandons all of
the crazy new worlds that Morrison is
dreaming up the solution is clear I'll
have to create a sigil and cast a
protective
so tun is a Tarrasch exam Multiversity
shall outsell backhand and Amazing
Spiderman combined it shall not flame
out faster than Marvel's new universe
Morrison I did my part it's completely
your fault if this Chaos magic baloney
doesn't work what's your favorite Grant
Morrison comic Doom Patrol Invisibles
all-star Superman were you able to
follow the storyline and final crisis if
so can you please explain it to me in
the comments